Megan rapino
who I am told as a soccer player Megan
rapino has a message for you
the message is that you need to go out
and get your 75th fauci ouchy and that
message
does not come free
Megan here Megan here
she is she's in the doctor's office
okay she got her shot apparently
and then boosted
I roll into the sheer let's go wait
let's go hey guys
so sad it's so cringy first of all
nobody thinks Megan rupino is cool I
assume there are a handful of very sad
liberal people who tell themselves that
Megan rapino is cool and so this ad is
geared toward them but even Megan
rapino's heart is obviously not in it so
sad the way she's trying to say hey
y'all
Megan we're gonna get our Bubba Bubba
booster yeah that's cool that's real but
it's so half-hearted no one really
believes it then you see why it seems so
contrived and half-hearted
there's a little line right there at the
top of the Instagram post and it says
paid partnership
that's a weird paid partnership
who she partners with oh it tells you in
the next line she's a Pfizer partner
#visor partner like so many others one
of my New Year's resolutions is to focus
on my health and with the tournament
down down under coming up this year
it's more important than ever that I do
so that's why I got my updated covid-19
booster something I've been meaning to
check off my to-do list points for
prioritizing Health hashtag I'm boosted
go to vaccines.gov to check your
eligibility and schedule an appointment
today
so you you know this was just written by
the marketing department either in the
government or or Pfizer you know this
because she's using hashtags like it's
2008. that's enough people don't do that
anymore that's not but anyway so okay
um hashtag I'm boosted hashtag Pfizer
partner I head on over to this
government website I've been meaning to
do this I feel really great
it's so important to go get your booster
you're so lucky to be able to have this
injection
if it's so great and if we're all so
lucky to be able to inject ourselves
with this experimental drug
why does Pfizer have to pay
Niche celebrities to promote it
if it's if it's so great
and if covet is so dangerous and scary
that we all were just waiting oh I can't
wait to get my vaccine
why does Pfizer why why does the
government why does whoever is footing
the bill here
why do they have to pay it when
specifically why do they have to pay
this kind of celebrity
that you know they're not calling me
they're not calling
Ben
they're not calling Tucker
and saying hey you want to be a Pfizer
partner because they know
then our audiences are going to say what
the hell is wrong with you people I'm
not going to get that vouchy algae no no
clot shot for me thank you
no I'm good thanks
but
the handful of people who follow Megan
rapino that's the target audience they
know these Libs
these libs are at least going to be open
to getting the shot
and then what's so crazy is is even the
lips even even the very people who
follow Megan rapino
are not clamoring to go get the fauci
ouchy
these these are the people who should
have been the first in the line
and yet even they are not even they need
to be bribed
and bought off to get the shot I wonder
why that is probably because it's not a
great shot
so that's what I would deduce
speaking of the biomedical Security
State
the UN is going to take action against
me
for daring to question the genius of Dr
fauci and the benevolence of our rulers
in the lab coats the U.N Secretary
General is calling for Global action
against Miss and disinformation
from everyone with influence on the
spread of me and this information on the
internet
governments Regulators policy makers
technology companies the media Civil
Society
stop the hate
set up strong guard rails be accountable
for language that causes harm
and as part of my report or common
agenda we are convening all stakeholders
around the code of conduct for
information Integrity on digital
platforms
and we'll also further strengthen our
focus on our means and this information
are impacting progress on global issues
including the climate crisis
the means and these information
and of course missing disinformation
just means anything that contradicts The
Narrative of the liberal Elite on any
given day so on the day where Dr fauci
said Don't wear a mask masks don't work
if you came out and said you should wear
a mask that would be missing
disinformation
but then five seconds later when Dr
fauci said actually you do need to wear
masks masks are very important masks do
work and you contradict to that and you
said actually you know I think masks
don't work that would be missing
disinformation the the the feature that
determines what the Miss and
disinformation is is just whatever the
Liberals are saying at this point and
you might say well who cares what the
U.N is warning about the UN doesn't have
any power
the UN doesn't have a ton of power in
itself but that's why the liberal Elites
now who are trying to censor what we can
say they're trying to go around the U.N
they're trying to even go around many of
the governments they're certainly trying
to go around the people they're trying
to build it into the platforms this is
the purpose of safety by Design which is
this proposal of the Australian e-safety
commissioner Julie Grant who's partnered
with the world economic Forum to get
this implemented around the world
because
what safety by Design says is Leia the
governments aren't going to really keep
up with all this stuff so we're just
going to embed our wokism into the the
speech platforms themselves then you've
only got to get it into three or four
speech platforms and all of a sudden the
libs can Implement their speech codes
their standards their taboos their
censorship at the drop of a head it'll
happen automatically from the platforms
that's happening right now and very very
powerful people are pushing for it
[Music]
foreign